pouvez-vous raconter un souvenir d'enfance avec
moi qui était important J'ai un
souvenir vif de vous errant dans ma chambre
c'est un jour en tant que tout-petit à nouveau seulement une
couche et ramassant une bille sur mon
sol
et la tenant comme le crâne de
votre Akande  Hamlet et le mettre aussi
loin que possible dans votre gorge et moi
atteignant tout mon ottoman dans
votre œsophage pour retirer le marbre
et sauver votre vie pouvez-vous décrire votre
enfance à quoi ça ressemblait de grandir
avec moi c'était génial
je suis je toujours  me sentais moins talentueux Hey
grandir avec toi m'a fait me sentir complètement sans
talent c'est à peu près bien je sais que
Phineas était Miss Phineas était le meilleur
grand frère du monde il était si gentil
et si attentionné et si gentil sauf
pendant un an il y avait comme un an
là où tu ne m'aimais pas du tout
il y avait comme une année tu avais un
âge terrible cette année-là j'étais j'étais ouais
mais Phineas était un grand
frère incroyable et il se souciait tellement et il l'était
alors il a sorti une bille  de  ma
gorge je lui ai sauvé la vie
ouais tu te souviens quand nous avons commencé à
faire de la musique ensemble comme moi je
me souviens quand nous avons commencé à faire de la musique
ensemble c'était fantastique
je me souviens je sens que notre
relation professionnelle est devenue de
plus en plus saine quand nous étions jeunes
nous avions l'habitude de  se chamailler de manière non professionnelle
quand nous étions jeunes beaucoup plus jeunes
qu'aujourd'hui, nous nous chamaillerions de manière non professionnelle
et maintenant je sens que nous l'avons choisie
professionnellement quand la musique est-elle devenue une
partie intégrante de notre relation euh
2015 oui je suppose que c'est je veux dire si tu
veux parler comme  technique comme quand nous
avons commencé à faire de la musique ensemble
2015 j'avais 13 ans tu avais 17 18 17 Turk
nice j'avais 17 ans j'ai 18 ans c'est
tellement fou c'est tellement fou c'est fou euh
et c'est quand nous avons commencé et
c'était comme si c'était juste vraiment pour le plaisir  c'était
comme s'il n'y avait aucune intention c'était juste
comme pourquoi ne pas faire ça
et mais honnêtement la musique a été très
importante et toute notre vie
comme avant que nous fassions de la musique  du tout, nous
avons toujours été la chose sur laquelle nous nous lions
à coup sûr comment la production pour moi a maintenant
changé depuis que nous sommes enfants, je sens que
je me suis amélioré à coup sûr ouais
j'étais je ne savais pas ce que je faisais ou  s
pointant vers des choses en appuyant sur des boutons
au début et non tu es si bon non
merci Billy je sens que je me suis
amélioré et je sens que tu es devenu
meilleur en produisant aussi et donc tu me rends
meilleur parce que quand j'ai une idée  nous allons
qui a essayé ça dans ce cas ouais et quand nous
avons commencé tu ne l'as pas fait du tout
mais ouais j'ai l'impression que je me suis amélioré
je suis content que tu ressentes ça aussi ce
serait triste si tu sentais qu'ils empiraient  tu
sais que je ne serais pas du tout là où je suis si
ce n'était pas pour toi alors
voilà c'est tout